Hello everybody!
We are Pongfinity
Welcome to a new episode of "Challenge Pongfinity"
Let's see what kind of challenges you guys have come up with this time!
This idea is from Jacob Knott
Otto, are you ready for this?
I'm ready!
You are really high up!
I feel like I'm riding a dinosaur!
Right in the face!
Okay, I got this!
I got this!
You got that one? - Yes!
We need another person on my shoulders!
We have had strangely many suggestions
that we should play with our hands
So, we are finally doing it!
Ouch!
That's actually pretty painful!
We are trying to shoot the apple with our table tennis bat
Onto the knife
And see if we can slice it
I think that I broke the apple
I think I sliced it!
Perfect slice!
Almost in the middle
I can't believe this actually worked!
Remember to subscribe here
And check out our previous
episodes there!
Until next time!